in the middle of this National Park sits
a striking testament to the beauty of
nature and the ingenuity of Victorian
age engineering this great big story was
made possible by the German National
Tourist Board and honza mark or travel
insurance
these stunning rock formations also
called the city of stone are known as
bass style or Bastille
located in Saxon Switzerland National
Park in Germany they are connected to
one another by the bath sky bridge the
sandstone rocks are covered in trees and
shrubbery and were created by water
erosion throughout millions of years the
first version of the bridge was
constructed in 1824 with wood but in
1851 a new version was built to help
with a steady increase in visitors today
the best eye bridge can be seen in
notable Hollywood films scenes from The
Chronicles of Narnia was shot here and
its viewing platform is easily
recognized in the grand Budapest hotel
the bridge towers around 650 feet above
the Elbe River the climb up is 487 steps
and because of heights like this the
park is part of a climbing and hiking
area that stretches into the Czech
Republic since the fall of the Berlin
Wall 30 years ago this site has become
an exciting attraction for all who visit
and the view from the top is well worth
the hike a walk along the bridge is the
perfect vantage point for panoramic
views of the mountains and the stunning
landscape of Saxony Germany
you
you
[Music]